[Musique]
ayalon c'est vrai qu'on a eu du mal à
rentrer dans à rentrer dans le match
je pense que vu le sco tiers et en ayant
voix mayotte en ayant fumé yacht show et
voilà que les filles les filles sont pas
rentrer avec la même envie la même
motivation
en tout la boulette et à la mi-temps de
pouvoir les relances et de leur faire
comprendre qu'on ait un match encore
demain et qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
basse aujourd'hui et à partir de cela
dont c'est vrai qu'on a abordé la
deuxième mi temps dans d'autres
dispositions
[Musique]
oui effectivement je pense que pour la
première fois on se présente ici c'est
une belle expérience quand même pour
nous après chez nous je pense que c'est
nous on joue pas totalement comme ça
mais c'est une découverte pour nous et
ça a été une belle expérience
là je pense que pour les prochaines
hausses on se préparera mieux plus que
sa valeur au sérum au niveau des tenues
peut-être numéro 3 on avait face à nous
des choix sur tous nos duels donc ne pas
trop sentir
et justement valorisé rapidement
ces récupérations de balles par des
contre attaques sur la deuxième mi temps
je pense qu'on fait plus de 70% des bus
sur des contre attaques ont démonté dame
[Musique]
déjà on va on va soigner les petits
bobos prendre des informations sur notre
pic puisque leur équipe a quand même
bouger et ça reste quand même une finale
ultramarines
donc ça serait bien pour ce groupe de
jeunes filles de pouvoir au moins au
moins gagner ce titre là et voir si on
peut faire quelque chose derrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]